I'm seriously just only human like you
guys Jessica Simpson proves that's true
opening up like never before
revealing details of childhood sexual
abuse and a battle with drinking and
pills I think I'm a little bit too on it
in some excerpts from her new memoir
open book obtained by people the 39 year
old reveals that she was sexually abused
as a child starting when she was just
six years old just says she shared a bed
with the daughter of a family friend
quote it would start with tickling my
back and then go into things that were
extremely uncomfortable the fashion
mogul says she kept the secret to
herself for years adding quote I was the
victim but somehow I felt in the wrong
six years after the alleged abuse began
just says she told her parents Tina and
Joe Simpson her mom responded by
slapping her dad's arm and saying I told
you something was happening as for her
dad he didn't say anything but just
explains that they never stayed at her
parents friend's house again and they
never talked about it again Jess says
she eventually turned to the bottle to
cope and she admits she was quote
killing myself with all the drinking and
pills
I'm definitely oh I think livin la vida
loca living a lie you for a living the
party or something I'm living it the
singer says it all came to a head after
a Halloween party in 2017 where she
recalls telling her friends she needed
to stop drinking which she admits was
easy for her because she was mad that
alcohol had allowed her to stay
complacent and numb Jess also says
another part of her recovery came
through therapy quote when I finally
said I needed help it was like I was
that little girl that found her calling
again in life I found direction and that
was to walk straight ahead with no fear
I truly feel like being iconic is being
you know just yourself and being very
natural and really just knowing how to
own yourself in addition to our memoir
which will hit shelves on February 4th
and an audio book that she narrate
it herself get excited because jessica
is also dropping six new songs songs
that she says are meant to inspire
people going through a tough time I am
all about helping others filter this I
know I know those down days quote it's
been a long hard deep emotional journey
one that I've come through the other
side with pure happiness and fulfillment
and acceptance of myself I've used my
pain and turned it into something that
can be beautiful and hopefully inspiring
to people
guys just hasn't released new music
since 2010 so these six new songs are
kind of a big deal but in 2015 she told
ET she definitely had making music on
her mind I feel like I'm at such a
comfortable place to like open my heart
and share so much with everybody so
music makes the most sense I can't wait
to hear her new music and I love how
jess is turning her pain into purpose
just when I thought I couldn't love you
more Jessica of course you can count on
et to bring you all the latest on Jess
so make sure to keep it locked right
here until next time I'm Hallie Stevens
see you soon
[Music]